what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I talk about this
week's treachery debauchery and
craziness so today shout out to the
production team King and blessing we are
in our brand new studio yay
[Music]
um before I start though guys make sure
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
alright so our first story today
we have you know us modern women just
have really tough problems you know I
know the men out there are out building
the buildings
um you know doing all the sewers garbage
collection but us women like we're
really oppressed in this Society we have
such a tough time so there was an only
fans model that came forward with um you
know just some really huge life
struggles that she's going through so
pull the pull the clip King
so I went to Google I went to Google I
put pinky doll naked and I clicked on
pictures and what I see what I see
there's a lot of page there's a lot of
page you keep swiping and swiping
swiping it don't stop it don't stop and
I see all this website how dare you
you're gonna let other people put my
face my body out here doing stuff like
that how dare you without asking an ID
where's the ID turns tell me that what's
up I'ma tell you I'ma tell you something
today I'ma Sue all of you all of you are
gonna sue you I'm gonna sue you y'all
want to play with me you're allow the
people post big job really cause you
know you're about to get paid well guess
what I'm about to get all that money all
that money okay so for those of you that
didn't know what she was talking about
this only fans model was very upset
because she typed her name on Google
and she was shocked that her only fans
content was not behind a paywall so for
those of you that don't know I did cover
this chick a couple of months uh maybe
weeks ago where she was going viral for
making basically sounds on Tick Tock you
know what swimming we're really breaking
the glass ceiling
we're really breaking barriers out here
and just you know becoming Millionaires
and billionaires through hard work and
adversity and yeah so this chick was
making
um sounds on Tick Tock and was going
viral and then she was she decided you
know let me just capitalize even more
only fans and now she is devastated that
her nudes have been leaked
and now she is going to sue all of you
so all of you that leaked her nudes
um watch out because the lawsuit is
coming it is coming
um but guys this is the problem in
society remember one out of every 25 of
us under the age of 35
is literally on only fans and that
doesn't include the chicks the Instagram
models that you know accept trips and
other uh Petty forms of prostitution
that women do on the daily and you know
I I was thinking about this and I really
think that and only fans in the dating
Market is the equivalent of jail time on
job history
yeah so you know
um women are gonna do crazy crazy
but my issue is when
the whining
another woman whining about the choices
that she picked I mean did anyone put a
gun to your head
and make you put your nudes on the
internet did anyone put a gun to your
head and say ma'am
only fans is the way no no and you know
even with all of this we still get
whining later
and now the patriarchy is just out
together because her nudes have been
leaked even though she posted them so
our next story there is a young woman
named Bobby that has taken over the
Internet
um you know a lot of people have some
theories that she's an industry plant
which I don't even really understand
what that is but she comes out of
nowhere and has a podcast that really
focuses on like dry humor and she starts
to get big names on this podcast like
immediately so she had Mark Cuban on she
had little yachty on and she really
broke the internet when she had Drake on
her podcast Drake doesn't even really do
interviews like that so the fact that
this girl comes out of nowhere and gets
Drake on her podcast
um was crazy so this young woman is a
mother of two thank you
and you know she filmed a video with
Drake in in his bed
um
you know but it wasn't anything too
crazy so you know we'll give her the
benefit of the doubt with that but the
internet really has been taking a storm
because out of nowhere Bobby deleted the
interview she did the interview with
Drake she went to his concert and then
out of nowhere she deleted the interview
so the internet has some theories about
what happened pull the clip
but it's very hard for me to imagine
what could have possibly happened
between them during the show that would
make them unfollow each other and then
also she would delete the interview that
interview is the biggest thing that
she's ever done in her life if she lives
to be 800 years old it will continue to
be probably the biggest thing that she's
ever done in her entire life 11 million
views
I don't get it I don't understand what
could have possibly happened that that
easily made anywhere from 60 to 80 000
the first goal maybe yeah I mean I'm
just looking at numbers and now that
move 11 million views yeah you're
talking at least 60 to 80 grand first
month I wonder if tiger was getting his
cut because you know Rack City playing
in that song in the video so I'm
wondering if I could get a cut because
if so that's dope me and you had are
beef about that our differences about
how you felt like you felt like he was
slandering and now she interviewed I
don't think so but she did interview
tiger I haven't seen her yet that's
correct but it is out there I feel like
this and Drake I love you I drink and
drive I get it but I I feel like he
liked that little girl I think he liked
or something about her that he liked
she's married once and once he didn't
get that action Drake they were married
I feel like he didn't he didn't say
nothing to her at the concert he came
and he just let
so you know we got Theory number one
they hooked up and then it didn't turn
out the way she wanted then she deleted
the interview Theory number two is that
she didn't hook up with him and then he
got mad uh I can't really imagine Drake
getting mad
I mean like that guy's got women lined
up for him so like one doesn't sleep
with him I can't really see him caring
my theory is number three where maybe
there was some dispute over
revenue or
maybe like a clip that was posted
something like that so they just pulled
it I don't know or maybe her husband
told her to take it down so Dave
portnoid comes forward and he decides to
ask Bobby himself
Lavon is like I heard that Bobby slept
with Drake and is getting divorced so I
asked her I DM Bobby what you asked her
did you sleep with Drake and are you
getting a divorce yeah she's like I'm
not coming commenting on that publicly
wait so you just outed her oh you just
added her not public comment
so the internet's going crazy everybody
is is thinking okay
she must have slept with Drake until
Bobby comes forward and she says that
Dave didn't show the full messages so
here we got the full messages here you
know she said I did not want to do this
podcast in the first place and now so
much negativity is coming from it I'm
gonna leave it alone after this but this
is the uncensored DM between Dave and I
Dave said my girlfriend said you hooked
up with Drake and got divorced I'm
saying it's not true I am not commenting
publicly but off the Record you're right
not true he said I knew I was right so I
don't know
I it's like I'm torn because part of me
wants to think the best and I'm like
well maybe she didn't but then part of
me is like well she was in bed with
Drake and it goes back to a common theme
you know as a married woman is it okay
to be in bed with a major celebrity
while married to another guy you know
and I I know there is rumors that maybe
her husband cheated but it's like what
does the future look like for her if she
leaves that marriage now she's a single
mother with two kids I mean
you know to each his own I guess but
what do you guys think let me know in
the comments did she sleep with Drake
did she not sleep with Drake you know I
guess the world will never know the next
story we have today is jazz Jennings
Jazz Jennings is an internet personality
that has been on TLC for over a decade
and Jazz Jennings was a boy that
transitioned to be a girl at a super
young age and growing up you know it
wasn't something that I really watched
but I I saw Clips like on TV here and
there of you know this young boy girl
trans basically saying that she
he he she you know he
um was happy that the mother
transitioned him
um however you know in the long run
these things really play out and the
funny thing is the leftist ideology
never stands this test of time no matter
what people on the left said their
ideology does not last and you see what
happens in the lives of people that
follow you know this sort of thing so we
have this clip that was put together
recently that's going viral on Jazz
Jennings pull it up at just three years
old a young boy's family determined he
was a girl before he could even write by
the age of seven he began social
transitioning and puberty blockers and
at the point of adulthood Jazz Jennings
is now yearning for the male experience
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we ever
yeah and honestly it's heartbreaking
that this kid you know the has done
irreparable damage to his body
um with with the mom guiding this thing
leading this thing it's funny you look
at the family dynamics of the kids that
are transitioning and it's almost always
the women that are pushing it it's
either you know the woman pushing it
with a super simpy guy or a single
mother and it's so sad because you see
what happens to women when we don't have
structure
um unfortunately propaganda works really
well on women you know it's just easier
when you think of things in general
society and I know this isn't all women
but it's kind of easier if you just
think of us as like kids us women
because honestly they show us you know a
video saying you're only a good mom if
you let your kid transition and boom a
big chunk of us just do it they show us
a video of a 12 year old that can't get
an abortion and you know we run to the
polls and that and I don't know what it
is about female nature but we are just
really susceptible two stupid ideas and
you see it in recent polls that are
coming out saying the next generation of
men is more conservative than ever but
the next generation of women is more
liberal than ever and you see this this
is the result of a hundred years of
propaganda this is the result of single
mother homes pushing this ideology onto
the children this is the result of
really a matriarchal society where women
have all the power and are pushing ideas
that the elites really are pushing on to
us because we're just kind of big
dummies I I know maybe people say don't
say it like that they're smart women I
know I know there are but guys it's like
we believe the craziest I craziest
ideologies and we push it on to our
children and that's why I really think
that this is child abuse because now the
kid is gonna have
side effects for the rest of his life
and he might not even realize how wrong
it was until he's like 25 30. I don't
know what day it's gonna happen but I'm
gonna predict Now That Jazz Jennings is
going to regret this whole thing and
it's funny because if you listen closely
In that clip he says that he just wants
to be happy and I think that's the
biggest lie we've sold men and women
um is that happiness is
something you can attain you know
there's some days where you're going to
be happy there's some days where you're
not going to be happy and this idea that
you know happiness is something we can
find when really I think it's better to
chase purpose meaning you know what
fulfills you because happiness is going
to come and go some days you're going to
be happy some days you're not going to
be happy and I just think what we've
sold women is that you should be happy
all the time and if we're not happy
something's wrong with you and we're
going to sell you a solution it's either
going to be the gender ideology
it's either going to be more freedom
hook up culture or you know some other
leftist propaganda is going you know to
fulfill us instead of what's supposed to
fulfill us which is a family and it's so
you know it's even more sad because I've
interviewed people that have gone
through like transition surgery and a
lot of them they can't go to the
bathroom the same the rest of their life
they can't reproduce and really it's
just mutilation happening in front of
our eyes and I think it's the saddest
thing
so you know there's so many women that
are just breaking glass ceilings you
know and along the way we're super quiet
Meek and humble and don't throw in
everyone's face and wine that's women we
don't do that except for this chick
Rachel zegler so she's the lead in the
new movie Snow White and a clip recently
came out of her basically saying that
you know it's not 1920 anymore women
have rights and she doesn't even like
the snow white film
now you could see how this is a bit
entitled how you might think
this chick is a brat you know it
not a good look Rachel so then she comes
forward with a super humble apology
a super humble and taking a ton of
accountability apology so pull the
footage you always gonna get taken out
of context and I know that at this point
I can't really stop people from doing
that because that's what my whole
existence on the Internet is just me
being taken out of context and
stuff which is fine that's what I signed
up for isn't it um but I never wanted to
come off as me being ungrateful for the
opportunities I have when I say that
this has been the biggest adjustment of
my life like understanding the way my
life operates now being who I am and the
things that I've been so fortunate to
make it comes with so much
ground so much ground that I never
thought I would be able to cover and
that people think I'm doing poorly and
other people think I'm doing gracefully
and I don't think I'm doing it at all
so when I tell you
that it's hard
I just mean to be inside my brain that's
hard
and I'm there 24 7. I can't I can't get
out of it and and I I don't know if that
will make sense but that's where I'm at
I'm so grateful for the things that I'm
able to do and a lot of what I'm able to
do is because of you guys
and I'm so unbelievably thankful for
that at the end of the day
I look at this trip and think if
somewhere like that can exist and so can
my tiny pink bedroom from New Jersey I
can also be having the greatest
time and simultaneously wishing people
would stop sending me death threats and
maybe that's a weird takeaway for this
video this
a life this is real it's filled with a
lot of Beautiful Moments and beautiful
people I have a loving family an
incredible boyfriend that I love so much
beautiful friends and family people that
I miss it's a it's a privilege to miss
people the way that I do but it's hard
and it's lonely it's very lonely I just
know that if that loneliness can exist
so can other things and I will be okay
maybe that's a weird takeaway
I just can't deal with the chicks
crying on camera
it's really I don't have a lot of
sympathy
um you know you're
you have a role that women would dream
of having and you said something
entitled the people comment on it and
instead of coming forward and being like
walking it back
she just says that I'm I'm in my brain
24 like let me get this straight so your
life is hard because you had a tiny
bedroom
you're in your brain 24 7.
and you have a great family
you know I mean she's young so hopefully
she'll grow out of this stuff but it's
like I just think Hollywood and
especially to young women getting that
much attention at such a young age can
be so detrimental and if you don't have
like really good people like checking
you around you especially that young
um I just think that's why we see so
many child stars go off go crazy and
especially you guys will notice like the
women go way crazier than the guys like
the guys will go crazy like a couple
like the guy on That's So Raven I think
he went to jail or whatever but it's
really the women that were kind of going
nuts like Selena Gomez it's going a
little nutty now you know Hannah Montana
Miley Cyrus kind of went a little nutty
you know oh Demi Lovato that's like
number one Nutty Nutty chick and it's
really sad because I just think women
are aren't meant to get like that crazy
attention at a young age
um and it just kind of leads to like
leftist ideology and and propaganda
so the next story today
um who in
you know I'm not gonna lie guys I don't
know much about Putin when it comes to
Russian history
you know I don't I don't know a ton when
it comes to what's going on in Ukraine
I'm not like your Ukraine Russia expert
but who it has really done some based
lately and you guys already know my
opinion I think we should ban porn
only fans birth control I would just
take it all away in Pearl's world but we
don't live in Pearl's world but in
Putin's world he actually agrees with me
on one of these things so who in band
Only fan in Russia that man woke up and
chose violence he said I I'm not in my
country not today and you know I think
what we're going to continue to see is
other countries fighting back against
this leftist propaganda as you guys know
there are certain countries in Africa
that have said no to passing gay
marriage laws and it's unfortunate
because in the U.S we really have not
seen a hard push back on a lot of this
leftist Marxist ideology this propaganda
that they're pushing in schools this
propaganda that they're pushing at home
and when you think about it guys men
really cannot avoid this stuff
how is a guy a God-fearing guy supposed
to operate in our society without being
bombarded with naked women you know he
opens his phone and what's on there a
bunch of naked women he goes outside and
in Vegas guys I just got back from Vegas
these chicks these chicks put stickers
on their boobs and that's it
so he goes outside the women are half
naked and you know only fans is
unfortunate because it really
I don't want to take his Advantage
because each person makes their own
decision but you know most men don't
have sexual access so really only 20 30
at most 50 percent of men are really
getting laid like that so most men are
really lonely most men are not having
sex so it leaves the bottom 50 to
roughly 80 percent of men sexless and
you know one of the you know
quote-unquote Solutions we've brought in
is not to you know pass policies that
don't incentivize promiscuity
um instead
we reward the promiscuity with only fans
and women are making millions of dollars
being a and you know I I started
off really libertarian
and you know I've never been like crazy
political one way or the other but
I started off as more of a Libertarian I
would say but the older I get the more I
see I do think societies should ban
things that are harmful to the society
as a whole like you know you see the
divorce rate Spike after the
implementation of birth control and no
fault divorce and are those are those
two policies really good for society is
it good for society when one out of
three women has an STD is it good for
society when one out of three women has
gotten an abortion you know and
when we're starting to get to the point
where we're not even at a replacement
population rate
um we beg the question when do lawmakers
step in and maybe take away some of
these freedoms like you know it's not
like we're free
you can't kill somebody you can't rob a
store so this idea that we should be
free to just do anything I think is
silly and you could argue that only fans
is predatory and sexless men you know
maybe I wouldn't go that far because
people make their own decisions but
really men cannot avoid like a guy that
wants to be a Christian guy wait till
he's married and not have women and not
be overcome by lust really is out
of luck in the west and it's really
unfortunate because we really see
Society like degrading before our eyes
we see all of these only fans workers
having kids and their kids having these
like crazy mental health problems like
how many Clips have we seen of these
chicks like wanting to get on a plane
and just like screaming or people
fighting in the street and it's so crazy
I was walking around London and like
even today I was taking my dog for a
walk and I just saw these two people
like screaming at each other and I I
just couldn't help but think like
you know I I didn't live in London but
I'll just say even in you know I was
just in Vegas and Like I go to a lot of
different cities the cities weren't
always like this you know the Homeless
Problem wasn't always this bad and the
homeless were a lot more like respectful
it wasn't like you know I mean they
would kind of like go under a bridge
they wouldn't be like sleeping in broad
daylight they wouldn't really be like
like following you like I was in Vegas
the other day and I'm sitting okay I'm
sitting on this bench
and freaking
this homeless guy sits next to me and
there's broken glass on the bench and
it's like a concrete one and then he
says I'm not going to stab you with the
glass and me I'm not about to you know I
mean he said he wouldn't so I was like
all right but I'm not about to sit and
find out you know what I mean I'm like I
am out of here I just start like light
jogging and
I I had to get the hell out of there and
I just kept thinking I'm like this
really wouldn't have happened like 20 30
even like five ten years ago and it
really gets you thinking like every big
problem in society is rooted to single
mother homes the criminals are from
single mother homes the mental
institutions are filled with people from
single mother homes
um the kids that drop out of school run
away from home single mother homes I I
guarantee the only fans workers if we
took a poll single mother homes there's
no problem in society that is not
encouraged and pushed by women by single
mother homes and really I believe that
there's a natural order in the world and
that it should go God men women children
and I really think evil happens when we
mess up the natural order of the world
so you know when men don't follow God
they follow Satan and they commit a
genocide right you know there's women
women that hit the age of 22 never
having had a positive relationship with
a guy in their life and when that
becomes common in a society I I really
think that's when you see an increase in
mental health problems crime and I
personally think that the only way
um that we can fix this is to stop
having policies that reward bad behavior
only fans rewards bad behavior the
government rewards bad behavior
at times men reward bad behavior and I
just think when we have this Society
where women can do whatever they want in
a face zero consequence
um you know we're in a tricky dangerous
place so let me know what you guys think
in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell and I will talk to you
guys next time